this week on brian ross investigates
the case for derek show them the legal
strategy that could lead to a not guilty
verdict
for the former minneapolis police
officer accused of the murder of george
floyd
a strategy laid out tonight by the
lawyer who has never lost a case
defending police officers he says the
videos
the drugs and chauvin's record could all
be used to mount
a successful defense plus the millions
of evangelicals who won't take the covet
19 vaccine
is this the mark of the beast and the
evangelical minister
trying to tell them that they should be
vaccinated i've been
called a heretic i've been told that
i've been
uh turned into an instrument of satan
i i've been threatened
uh physically the thoughts of reverend
rob shank
on how to overcome the resistance led by
religious
and political leader there are times
when it's hard
to tell an evangelical from
a hard right political conservative
and vice versa and this week's winners
and losers
in the media see if you agree with the
choices made
by the editors of mediaite would you
agree
that you and the president and brian
dees the economic advisor
on this program last week you all
exaggerated the jobs impact
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with the trial of
derek shovin it's now the turn of the
defense to make
their case the
defense is led by eric nelson
minneapolis criminal defense attorney
he's taking the high profile role in the
courtroom
but there's a team of lawyers working
with him paid out of a special defense
fund
not just for shoving but for any officer
who might face legal charges
the estimated cost for chevin's defense
is up to
a million dollars
so is there a compelling case to be made
on behalf
of derrick shelvin to get an answer to
that question we're joined by anthony
pope a leading trial lawyer in new york
or new jersey
who has defended a number of police
officers and never lost a case
mr pope thank you so much for joining us
let me begin if you're the lawyer for
derrick shoven
what's your argument to the jury you
know brian i'm going to start off with
the tape
um the tape looks at first blush very
damning
but when you look at it you have to ask
a very clear question
why would a police officer be doing
something that he thought
was either going to hurt someone or god
forbid kill someone
when he knows all these video cameras or
focused on him
he the nonchalant attitude that the
prosecutor tries to portray
is one that he felt he was doing his job
it was routine
he was trying to restrain someone who
when they first tried to put him
into the back of the car said that he
was claustrophobic
and he didn't want to go in the back of
the car so they call for an ambulance or
another
you know vehicle to get him there and
they place him in a prone position
on the ground for purposes of
maintaining
law and order and making the arrest
you go further with that police tactics
are not etched in stone every tactic
or every policy has to be based on the
totality of what's going on at the time
hindsight is only always 20 20. so
does an officer get up in the morning
and say i'm going to kill somebody
or i'm going to hurt somebody so bad
that i'm going to turn my life
upside down my life my family's life
that's not the way it happens
and these things occurred and you have a
man who unfortunately had
serious heart disease he was on a great
many drugs
so all of this contributed to a
circumstance
under which unfortunately this man
succumbed
to the stress the anxiety the drugs
his medical condition and the restraints
that the police officers put on him
but it's a combination it was a perfect
storm
for this to happen without any intent by
the officers to cause this harm
or this death to this person and that's
the way this case has to be portrayed
mr pope that nine minutes and 29 seconds
does that not
show a reckless disregard for the life
of george floyd
you know brian there's no question that
it is unusual
i i'll admit that to you and and it's
the type of case
that if you take it i think you're
really shooting in some regards for a
lesser included offense
i mean i'll be very honest with you i
think the judge was appropriate and
charging or he indicated he's going to
charge manslaughter in the second degree
i certainly do not see murder in the
second degree
uh and i and i don't see those top
offenses
i think there's a clear i think there's
a very good chance
that a jury could certainly find
manslaughter and the second degree
and even though as an attorney you'll
shoot for a complete acquittal
you have to realize that the further you
get
and the more you make of your case the
less
likely it is that they're going to go
for one of the higher offenses either to
one or the two murder charges
and possibly come back with a
manslaughter so i think
that's a more likely scenario but i
think a complete acquittal in a case
like this
based on the totality of everything i've
seen it's going to be tough
mr pope a question for you from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
why do you think this keeps happening
there was another police shooting
resulting in a death this week
is there something that happens to
officers when they put on that badge
i i don't think it's something that
happens when they put on the badge i
think sometimes it happens after they've
been working too long
and they've been too exposed to a
criminal element
and gangs and drugs and guns and always
being concerned every time you go up to
a car whether somebody's going to pull a
weapon on you
and there's a desensitivity almost that
takes place
it doesn't condone the actions of any
police officer
that takes the law in their own hands or
uses force
that is not proportional to what needs
to be done
under no circumstances should that ever
be done we're all civilians
we're all subject to being stopped by
the police or questioned by the police
so we certainly don't want police acting
in a way that's
overboard but unfortunately we're
dealing
in some areas where the amount of crime
the amount of time that officers are on
the street
has a tendency sometimes to skew them in
a direction where they're always
thinking it's a gun it's a knife
somebody's going to run us over
you know we have to fight with somebody
or someone's going to resist us
it's not a great setting and certainly
any opportunity to change that any
opportunity to send these officers in
other areas
where they're constantly not exposed to
gangs
or drugs or guns i think could be
helpful
i think alternating officers to
different areas
might be very helpful to try to avoid
these situations
and finally let me ask you mr pope how
do you rate the job done so far
by eric nelson the lawyer for derrick
shoven you know i hate the second guest
lawyers because these type of cases
really have to get in your dna brian
but i was surprised to see that they
never made a comment at all about the
video
on opening and then something happened
today when i was watching it
the defense attorney asked the doctor
the cardiologist
are you saying that if officer
if rather if mr floyd got into the back
of the car
that he would not be dead today and he
said he looked at him and said
yeah and i scratched my head and i said
why did he ask that question that's the
whole point the prosecution's trying to
make
that the fact that they put him in a
prone position put the knee on the guy's
neck
is what caught was the significant
factor in causing his death
why he asked that open-ended question to
that
expert i thought i missed the preface to
it i thought did he say something before
and i just didn't hear it
but no so i gotta hope that there's
something in their bag of tricks there
that
they're gonna be able to pull something
out that they'll be able to tie that
in but brian uh you know i i wish
everyone the best and i hope justice is
served but so far what i've seen
i don't see the enthusiasm i i you've
got to attack these witnesses
but anyway enough is enough okay
all right thank you anthony pope so much
uh appreciate your input into this
and we'll see what happens in the coming
days
up next on brian ross investigates
why the covid19 vaccine is being
resisted by so many evangelicals
we'll take a close look with an
evangelical minister you're watching
brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
in the race to get america vaccinated
for covet 19
some 40 of christian evangelicals say
they'll refuse to take the shots so we
wanted to know what's behind all that
we're joined now by reverend rob shank
an evangelical minister and president of
the dietrich bonhoeffer institute
in washington d.c reverend shank thank
you so much for joining us tonight
it's my pleasure let me ask you why are
so many evangelicals
refusing to take the covet 19 vaccine
well there's both a simple answer to
that and a very
complicated one i'll spare you the
latter
and go to the more simple explanation
and that is that
evangelicals have trained themselves
and been trained to be very suspicious
of two things
one is the government the other
unfortunately is science uh
and both of them come together in the
vaccine
uh now complicating even that
is uh the political atmosphere
because american evangelicals
particularly white
american evangelicals are
have been highly politicized there are
times when it's hard
to tell an evangelical from
a hard right political conservative
and vice versa so you put all those
things together
and you get a perfect storm of
opposition
we've seen some evangelical ministers
raising the question of the mark of the
beast
covet 19 vaccine versus triple six
is this the mark of the beast
should i be vaccinated should you be
vaccinated should you be crying for the
vaccine
what is meant by that what's the fear
well again this goes back
to a certain interpretation
of a series of passages in the new
testament particularly in the book of
revelation the
the final book in the new testament that
speaks to many of the future
and in the future there will be this
world government run by
a global dictator who will among other
things
persecute what we would term
bible-believing christians and one of
the ways
he will persecute my community in this
interpretation
is that we will refuse to take
the mark of the beast this symbol of
uh allegiance or devotion
uh to the dictator and lately it's
become
the idea that it might be uh a microchip
uh you know that's inside the formula of
a vaccine
uh you're pressured or maybe even
ordered by government
to submit to taking the vaccine
therefore you are forced
to become a devotee of this false
prophet and a world dictator
so you know this becomes a kind of
fantastical conspiracy that's really
quite modern
what do you say to that well a couple of
things
one is i remind them that it's god
who speaks to us through the prophet
isaiah and says
come let us reason together
says the lord he invites us to engage
uh with him
reasonably that reason is an
attribute of god so this kind of
fear this inordinate
uninformed uh
almost paranoia is not reasonable
reverend shank one of the arguments
against the vaccine by evangelicals is
that it somehow and i think this is
totally false
connected to fetal tissue it is
incumbent upon the body of christ
to step up and speak out against the use
of our tax dollars
to create anything made from aborted
fetal tissue
and that is raised a lot uh in my
community
um you know if you look
at the data and again
the science and inform yourself you'll
see that's not true
of you know some of the formulations
there are distant connections but again
this gets into
a question of christian ethics
and uh the question of the greater good
so if there is a way for us even if you
consider
abortion uh evil
or a bad thing it is happening
it is occurring and the net result of
that
can be turning what we consider to be
something uh you know
deleterious or immoral
you can turn that to something good
reverend shank when you challenge some
of these beliefs some of these theories
do you get blow back from evangelicals
from your fellow evangelicals
oh i've been called a heretic
i've been told that i've been turned
into an instrument of satan
uh i've been threatened
uh physically uh
but again you know here i sound like the
preacher i'm sorry but i
am uh jesus said rejoice when
people speak ill of you
because they're really
going after me because you represent me
as an evangelical
my job is to represent christ not myself
and he said we're to take care of our
neighbors
let me ask you finally what would it
take to persuade evangelicals can they
be persuaded is there a way to persuade
evangelicals to take the vaccine
well you know i wrote a memoir about my
own journey from the hard
christian religious right to the place i
am now which i think is much closer
to the message that jesus came both to
proclaim
and to model for us and i called it
costly grace
and evangelical ministers rediscovery of
faith
hope and love so i take people back
to what is the most loving thing we can
do for
our family our friends
our fellow church members the
communities we live in
well it's very simply this we can help
save their lives by
stopping this virus at ourselves
and one way you can do that is by being
vaccinated
because you stop the progress of the
virus
and its mutations that are so
threatening to your neighbors
and to those you love to your parents
your aging parents
uh to your own uh close loved ones
maybe to your pastor who may be older
there's all kinds of ways you practice
love and one way
is to stop this virus in its tracks
reverend rob shank thank you so much for
being with us here on the law and crime
network
thank you coming up next this week's
winners and losers in the media
tucker carlson back on the list you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaites
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor in chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
in aidan we begin with your first winner
chris wallace at fox news
once again with his questions for both
republicans and democrats that were
penetrating and precise
but it turns out the study you're citing
from moody's analytics
says the economy will add 16.3 million
jobs without the infrastructure bill and
2.7
million more with it so it doesn't as
you said last sunday create
19 million jobs again
secretary but a judge why mislead folks
you're right i should have been more
precise would you agree that
you and the president and brian dees the
economic advisor on this program
last week you all exaggerated the jobs
impact
those are good questions and chris
wallace aidan really good questions and
getting uh people to judge the secretary
of transportation to admit that he
should have been more precise
is a you know it's a goal for any sunday
uh show anchor and i think that's chris
wallace proving why he's one of the
better
of the sunday show anchors he also had
an interview with greg
abbott the governor of texas in which he
pressed him on why
he was not critical of donald trump uh
when
he was there was a mistreatment of
migrants at the southern border and is
now harshly critical of joe biden
and his handling of the migrant crisis
um so it's really two
very pointed uh series of questions for
members of both parties
um and that's really why chris wallace
we think is one of the best sunday show
anchors and is a must watch every sunday
in the show of course that he hosts is
fox news sunday
without a doubt let's turn to fox news
tucker carlson your loser this week
for his comments that sunset were just
blatantly racist i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest
the democratic party is trying to
replace the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world
but they become hysterical because
that's that's what's happening actually
let's just say it that's
true one person equals one vote if you
change the population you
dilute the political power of the people
who live there
obedient voters from the third world
aiden i heard that correctly
yeah you did brian i'm rarely shocked by
things that i see on cable news now this
segment was
truly shocking now tucker carlson has
argued for years that democrats are in
favor of immigration
um because they like immigrant voters
and they think they'll vote democratic
now that he's often been accused of
racism whenever he puts forward that
argument
this was an example of him actively
embracing the sort of
more racist undertones of it which is a
theory called replacement theory
which is a theory that's held by white
supremacists which argues that non-white
people are being imported to the country
and into western civilization uh white
supremacists often argue that it's jews
that are doing the importing
uh in order to replace white people uh
were considered more pure by these white
supremacists
now this segment was tucker carlson
arguing that that theory
is not actually racist but that it's a
voting rights issue uh the fact that he
said
you know that these are more obedient
voters from the third world
i think is lifting up the mask a little
bit and showing that this is truly a
racist theory
and tucker carlson's embrace of it um
you know it's basically putting a
sophisticated argument around
upon something that is just incredibly
base and racist and that's why you have
the anti-defamation
now and calling for him to be fired by
fox news
all right aidan thank you so much thanks
to all of you for joining us
and thanks to our great staff at long
crime for getting us on the air
and off the air every single week
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
you